take on Mars has been designed with
modding in mind from start to finish
although it may not be obvious at first
glance everything in the game may be
replaced rewritten or built upon this
series of videos will help to take on
Mars ultimately to get started with
creating additional or new content for
the game
in this first chapter we will look at
how and where take on mass looks for its
data and how it can be modified first
off let's start up the loader and
extract the game data to directory of
our choice this will allow us to see
exactly what is in table Mars
the games pack files contain all game
data including scripts and models keep
in mind that this only extracts the data
and is not wanted
you can place any of this data into a
mod or add-on to script files are of
particular interest script dhalsim and
CC game go see these two files are the
core files loaded directly from the
internal game engine the first the
script or scene is loaded on a game
engine start including where you start
up workbench and contains core functions
and entity definitions biotechnology the
latter script CC game of C is loaded
when the game mechanics are initialized
and contains extended engines functions
and most important the campaign also
quite
modifying these two scripts allows you
to change the entire game if desired and
can allow you to make a completely
different type of game it's real-time
strategy or first-person shooter make
them take on Mars a truly sandbox
platform to build on the prototype h
sprint is also very important
containing a script API function
definitions from
this is the first place to look in
searching for all the functions I handle
great in physics object dealing with
in addition to this the entity stock XML
file is quite a game editor in the
webmin Chariton seems to define the edge
two parameters each entity type this
file is also loaded directly by the
enter scripts for entities the free fly
camera and vehicle conflicts are all
located within scripts folder for
example the entities rh5 contains
definitions of basic entities by the
game such as the base game and
which all take my pasta
so to speak this folder is real nuts and
bolts of Taylor Momsen vehicle conflicts
are located in the scripts entities
conflicts vehicles folder has text
editable not seen f2 files
vehicle controller states which have the
functionality of each vehicle are
located in the script and entities
controllers folder as text F double dot
H file the controller strings contain
practically all functionalities of
individual movements the aforementioned
convicts define individual parts of the
vehicle
what model to use their toughness joins
that bind them together and also which
scripts to use these scripts then make
the vehicle what it is so a 6b a verbal
is made to act as such in these controls
waiting this also means you can make an
airship aeroplane or rocket ship as you
see fit next strings are saved in an XML
file for each language and are located
in the scripts folder as strings
underscore language XML please note
though that right now only the English
language is correctly used you will also
notice many other texts in the file
dating back to when the engine was used
for current commander guy initial all
take on mass texts have a prefix of comm
underscored
models are stored as binarized dot xrb
files in the obj folder which are
exported from the text-based dock TXO
files the workbench editing suite
features a model viewer to allow viewing
plus dot t-- XL and XR b files and
allows exporting from t XO - XO v the
input process from the dot FBX format to
the T Excel format will be documented
elsewhere so for now let us move on to
sound sound files may be stored as WAV
audio GG and are located in the sounds
form also note to the dot h txt files
directly in the sounds vault which are
the sound shader files the shaders - dot
H file in his folder is loaded directly
by the engine and contains includes for
the other files in that folder
configuring sounds may be done in a text
editor or in the workbench editing suite
using the sound editor settings will be
covered in another chapter now we will
look at textures their material
definitions textures are stored as TGA
and doc DDS files textures can be stored
anywhere but for organizational purposes
take on Mars has them separated between
GUI textures and model textures textures
for models are usually stored in the
same location as the dot X LP model file
and are also usually stored as dot DDS
to conserve disks myths associated with
model textures are also material
definitions models do not directly
linked to a texture file or rather our
material definition sometimes referred
to as a material shader these shaders
work with several textures at once
including normal Maps environment maps
and so on even the artists maximum
control of how his mole is displayed in
game
similar to the way sounds are loaded
materials have a call file materials law
H in the materials folder which is
loaded directly by the engine and other
material files are included within GUI
texture zhonya are stored in the GUI
phone and I usually stored as dot TGA
files the textures folder contains
textures that are easy used for the
terrain or for particle and post process
effects such as the thermal vision color
bars particle effects are stored as
stock PTC files in the particle folder
and are not binarized meaning they can
be edited in a text editor design
that said particles also have their own
editor in the workbench editing suite
graphical user interface GUI data is
stored in a GUI folder visual GUI
layouts are stored as text notes both
dot layout files and feature their own
GUI layout editor in the workbench
editing suite image sets used for icons
and buttons are stored as dot image set
files with an Associated TGA image file
and also feature their own GUI image set
editor in workbench
game forms are stored in the GUI fonts
form as binarized dot FNT files with
associated TGA or dsm-5
these are created using form
which we covered elsewhere animations
for vehicles characters and cameras are
stored in the am phone which also
contains definitions
animations themselves are stored as my
eyes got a an m5
which are converted from non bio mais
dot exe files next the physics folder
contains physics material definitions
which define friction and restitution
for different material types
it also contains ragdoll skeleton setups
the cutscenes folder contains 13 files a
stock cut cutscenes support custom
camera animations character and vehicle
Nations cute sounds and so on although a
classic cutscene shoots water they take
on Mars this only really applies to the
mission trawler and mainly the
modifications
next on the world's pad folder contains
object pattern brush dot pad files which
allow painting objects onto the terrain
in workbench
these are also created and edited using
the game editor in the workbench editing
suite moving on the worlds folder
contains the actual location files as
text readable dot ent files these are
edited in the game editor in the
workbench editing suite and contain the
world's rocks terrain grass and so on
objects specific to scenarios or
campaign are created in the in game
editor in the worlds forum you will also
find the sky dot XML file which contains
individual sky presets these may be
modified in the game editor in workbench
and may also be cloned copied or renamed
in sky preset manager in Bourbon Street
additionally you will also find text F
school not PLA files in the world's
water which are Planetary definition
files
the camera offset and so on some files
are not stored in the game's pack files
and are left unpacked directly in the
game steam directory under steam
location steam apps common take on Mars
these are not packed due to an earlier
technical limitation which has since
been resolved and will likely be packed
in the future here you find the game
scenario files in the scenarios folder
each scenario is stored as a textual dot
SCN file with an Associated not jpg file
the campaign sub folder contains the
mission scene in the game's locations
when playing the space program mode
scenario files are searched for
dynamically by the game script so a new
scenario is located automatically by the
game next videos are stored as WMV files
in the videos folder which is convenient
as they may be viewed on a Windows PC
outside the game's world the config
lists for per contains lists for objects
vehicles and so on each list is stored
as a text edge does the FG list file
which contains a path a main to each
vehicle precept object preset and so on
in the game these lists are searched or
dynamically by the game scripts so a new
list is read automatically by the way
the world's folder here contains text
editable lock files for each game
location
these are definition files for each
location and define where on the
relevant planetary body location is
reentry offset and velocity the gravity
of location the image to be used for the
map and so on
you